a lot of people say that the area is
getting more and more gentrified does
gentrification also necessarily bring in
hipsters in order to determine if this
is true we've made a couple handy-dandy
bingo cards with a couple things that
you might expect to see from hipster
culture we're gonna go down to the arts
district right now and find out how many
of these things we can check off which
will hopefully help us determine whether
or not gentrification means
hipsterification
we moved into downtown l.a about nine
years ago now the area has changed
pretty significantly see the way things
usually happen is there's cheap rent in
some part of town usually because it's
all warehouse is kind of scummy and then
all the artists move in there because
artists need cheap rent thing is an
artist move into an area it gets really
really
hip
terribly hip when they get terribly hip
well then all the people who want to
associate themselves with being terribly
hip move into those areas and we are
going to go out today into the gender
fight arts district and see just how
terribly hip it has gotten right behind
us is some great construction going on
the sign of gentrification now we're
looking for a lot of different things
but we'll see what we can find all right
well i'm getting off i got one right
there how's everyone working gonna
freaking ampersand neon sign really it's
an ampersand and a business name like
fig and leaf and poppy and rose they're
so proud of the ampersand they got a
neon sign made for it actually that's a
separate store called the art book store
with an ampersand is the logo
[Music]
it's we got the circle with the x logo
it's not it's not in its purest form but
we got it if we find a pair of joggers
or canadian tuxedo i am i'm gonna win
and i'm not counting mine i brought
these i brought these to blend in so
like people wouldn't look at me funny
here
[Music]
oh the angel wings should put down the
angel wings oh we should have done angel
wings
things you guys
angel wings iron showings to increase
foot traffic to your area you do some
angel wings on your wall
like this
and what do i have to do something like
this
i can't i can't go in there why it's
like a vampire thing i found a geometric
neon
yeah i'm gonna claim it
oh i just need to find a
obscure graphic tee
we left this off the list and it's the
easiest oversight edison bulbs
old-fashioned filament light bulbs
because you know everybody's all about
the environment right except when it
comes to their light bulbs
low efficiency
those look good right
just gotta find an obscure graphic tee
oh me too oh whoever gets it first gets
the bingo if i if i can find some natty
joggers i win
i'd like to take a minute of your time
to tell you a story back when sam and i
moved out here in
late 2008 early 2009 we're working on
our very first feature film and we
wanted to shoot another video just for
fun just to shoot what we'd like to
shoot a little action video fan film you
guys might know the name now it's frozen
crossing we shot parvet minnesota we
shot the second part out here in la and
at the time we're just two kids didn't
really know what we were doing didn't
have any connections didn't have any
credits under our belt nothing like that
literally just two kids that moved in
down the street and at the other end of
the street was a filming location known
as the poodle parlor and they shot music
videos there movies a whole bunch of big
stuff they even hosted parties and in
fact there's a documentary i think it's
on netflix called exit through the gift
shop about banksy and that big party at
the end of the piece took place at the
pool parlor which had been filmed just a
few months before salmon moved out here
now the guy who won that place his name
was joel and
joel
let us shoot there he let us shoot
frozen crossing there for free well
technically for a bottle of whiskey
but basically for free so this place you
know probably pulls in multi thousands
for all these big shoots just let two
kids come in
and shoot a film there a video there
because he was nice enough to support us
with what we were doing
[Music]
he saw there's two kids who are
passionate about filmmaking they wanted
a chance at shooting something i'd never
shot anything in a professional set like
this before over the years as we kept
shooting more videos we were eventually
able to pay joel a little bit for
shooting in his warehouse or shooting up
back we'd always cut us a deal he'd
always keep it affordable because we
were his neighbors he helped us out
yesterday we learned that joel passed
away a few weeks ago
and i want to take a minute and
kind of share this video as a little bit
of a memory of him because he's been
such a big part
of our filmmaking careers and he's
helped make corridor digital what it is
today so in memory of joel i wanted to
encourage you to do something nice for
somebody to
understand when somebody needs a favor
someone needs you to help them for
something just like joel helped us out
and helped kick off our youtube careers
go out there help somebody out do
something for somebody else as a favor
just selflessly to help them out because
you never know what you might help them
achieve with that thanks for all your
help joel
a lot of people can describe
gentrification in different ways but i
think the best way to put it is
gentrification is when businesses begin
blooming in an area that are not
designed for members of that actual
community when you come to the arts
district where artists are supposed to
live so to speak in rent is cheap etc
and you build a luxury coffee store
luxury goods store you're clearly not
catering towards the people who actually
live in that community you're trying to
attract outside people into that zone
the arts district has kind of become a
haven of people who want to kind of
define themselves by where they live
one thing we didn't call out on the
actual bingo sheets is the abbreviated
words
kitchen downtown l.a
highlighting feels like youtube video is
one thing but
building a whole museum around it i mean
wow
[Music]
remember when steve was talking about
all the people being evicted that one
building on spot it's that one right
there where it says angeles desk company
on it that's the one bought by a swedish
investor kick everybody out
[Music]
dude
uh which one it's just a little piece of
paper has my name on it right here yeah
johnny yeah that's great dude carmichael
nice to meet you nice to meet you
i want to claim them i just did dude i
just got joggers
now all i need is a wide-brimmed hat or
a graphic
vibrant hat
i clipped that i cleaned that i saw it
first
i saw it first well i don't have it i
don't have a bingo yet so come on man
dude makes me so angry that you got all
those ah i either can do geometric
tattoo graphic hoodie or canadian tuxedo
we're having a little bit of fun here
poking some fun at hipsters but no
actual hate towards them it's cool
people want to wear canadian tuxedos and
you know rock and mustache that's all
cool you gotta be able to laugh at
yourself a little bit right all right
let's go see if i can get this big
classic
see any long brims over there
i think i'm winning i think i won
that's definitely more street that's on
hipster at all
you're sorry nothing like it you tell me
you're telling me those aren't joggers
those are joggers i don't i don't want
to win off of that though that's the
thing i don't want to win off of that
it's got to be it's got to be a clear
win all right all right
that's him that's it that's it that's my
pad yes it's not a wide brim it's super
hipster but it's not exciting if i get
one more like that give it to me that's
a half i mean if you're terribly hip
enough to run a pit helmet to your bike
yeah pith with a th yes it's pissed he
had sandals and and joggers on
a wide brimmed hat worn by a member of a
film crew or a construction guy or
something that's not hipster because
that's 100 utilitarian they are out
there in the sun working all day they
need that hat to keep the sun off their
neck and out of their eyes i'm strolling
down the street huh yeah i mean i guess
i could just count myself here and then
submit myself to ridicule and but i'll
win maybe maybe that's the end of the
story here that we're all wrong and it
turns out it's actually not that
hipstery at all playing sam's drop
crotch pants now i'm playing in my pants
you just do that
and then i went
it was in front of me all along staring
me in the face we're part of the
gentrification
it's ripping right here
oh my god it is dude oh no oh my god
it would be funny if i walked i did the
whole video in normal clothes and then
it just cuts those having a conversation
you look over and i'm like all like this
it's a goddamn and i think the real
message here is that
whether we like it or not we're a part
of this progress marches forward it'll
continue to march forward no matter what
parts of cities will get more expensive
that's how cities improve
it's all about striking that right
balance though also
i just don't like trendy hip copy shops
so whatever i'll be a convergent about
that